there are basic principles of
mathematics and basic principles of
personal finance that are always the
same for instance I would tell you there
is never a time that you would use a
credit card you can't say that there you
can't convince me that there's certain
times you should use a credit card they
suck they're a bad product they don't
work and I think the same thing's true
of whole
life if you die with whole life life
insurance your beneficiary gets paid
only the face amount after you've paid
20 times more for the policy that I can
refute that very easily if it is AR if
it if a policy is arranged properly a
person can receive not just the face
amount of the policy but in addition
they can receive the value of the cash
account no they can't not unless it's a
b not unless it's an AB Universal in
which case you paid more for it to start
with